well it's all about uh oviedo here today
and the thing that he struggled with the
most is pitching
ahead in the count so i think if he
pitches ahead in the count today with
his stuff
he is going to get his first win today
that'll add to oviedo's walk totals
that are high and are going and liner
towards center field and this will put
runners at first and third
key brian hayes on the 3-2 pitch and
derek
shelton sending frazier so in business
here's reynolds
and this ball lined towards center field
on bay's hit
reynolds drives in fraser hayes is going
to try for third
the throw is late and offline throwback
to first reynolds
is in there it's an rbi single the
pirates lead one to nothing
moran four for ten in the series runner
goes from first and dropped
and the runner will score and it is two
to nothing as molina
drops the pitch that should be a pass
ball there's a 3-2 outside ball
four moran will work a walk two of those
issued by oviedo so far
there it is inside another walk so he's
gone three balls on every hitter except
for reynolds who singled on the first
pitch he's walked
three two strikes on polanco
swaying and a miss and he struck him out
so you're a ground ball and a double
play from being out of it
here's gammel batting with the base is
full wow
forced in a run the pirates lead three
to nothing that's big
krennic to the plate max credit gets it
at bat before he throws a pitch in the
big leagues
and he hits it up the middle the young
two is left
and the pirates pick up three 41 pitches
in the first inning for johann oviedo
three-nothing pirates lead and max
kranick takes a major league mound for
the first time in his career
23 years old
and he will record his first out through
the raindrops gammel
two pitches one out and a swing and a
fly ball
head out to left deep gammel to the
warning track
and he will make the catch just it out
two gone
now he faces nolan renato welcome to the
major leagues
on the fly ball toward right and max
kranik
is going to have a one two three first
inning in his big league career and his
family
loving it max kranik back out to pitch a
one two three first inning
went right back down and away with a
fastball got him swinging and missing
and tyler o'neill
four up four down and there's his first
major league strikeout he's getting a
lot of firsts out of the way here early
and bounced and a fair ball and a long
throw for hayes
he got him all unbelievable
key brian hayes one of the best you'll
ever see
out there and through a strike
to moran to get molina
look where he throws this ball yeah from
the stands
guy can play some third that is
sensational
pitch swing of the felt tip struck about
max craddock
has uh retired six in a row to start his
big league career obito had a one two
three second inning he has struck out
three he has walked four
here's a swing and a ground ball to
first one pitch and one out as moran
rounds out to paul goldsmith
the fly ball into left center plenty of
room for
dylan carlson to wave three infielders
on the right side
for polanco the one-two pitch he swings
and strikes out on a breaking ball in
the dirt
so oviedo went out for the second inning
acting like it was nothing nothing
and worked a three up three down inning
striking out two he gets to pirates
three up three down in the third
three-nothing pittsburgh
three-nothing the pirates have the lead
as we go to the bottom of the third
inning
and a fly ball to right and polanco
there
and tap her back to the mound mccrannick
has it he'll shovel it onto moran
for the second out and he gets him so
krannic perfect through three more
timing coming up
here's the 1-0 and a swing and a fly
ball out to
right field new bar toward the line
can't get their base hit it'll drop in
front of him
camel with a big turn around first but
he'll hold with a one out single
and a base hit for adam frazier after
lining out and now
gamma may be a bit of a stumble but it's
first and third
and bouncing ball and a flip and a safe
call and
give hayes an rbi as the buckos take a
four nothing lead
in the fourth inning yeah give frazier a
little nod there
nice hustle on the second base beating
that force play
now reynolds fly ball center field
dropping and in there for a hit another
run
and frazier's in to score the pirates
lead
nothing a q shot off the bat of brian
reynolds
pirates leading at five nothing heading
to the bottom of the fourth inning in
saint louis
and a swing and a week fly ball out to
right four innings
42 pitches and catch is made
12 up and 12 down for max crannick in
his major league
debut jake woodford is the new pitcher
for the cardinals as
johan oviedo goes just four on the pitch
swinging a fly ball head out to deep
left field o'neil back turns around
there it goes
home run for polanco the opposite way
the pirates lead six nothing as polacco
has homer on back-to-back games
and that's the approach you'd love to
see gregory polanco stick with
it's been a while since we've seen an
opposite field homer
here's ben gamble swings and sends one
out
toward deep center field carlson back
and this one's gone
ben gamel with home run number two
yeah the pirates have hit a pair of home
runs here in the fifth
and they lead seven to nothing well i
don't know if there's some
little extra wind or what but he tagged
that one another rbi for gamble today
yeah i mean he got out just smothered
this ball
and had the perfect backspin i mean
backspin carries topspin
won't carry as far and boy he
backspawned this ball
and it just wasn't coming down one ball
one strike two outs fifth inning
max kranik bouncing ball to second
huh how about this start
this is some kind of special five
perfect innings for max krennic on
50 pitches in his major league debut
well we're through five innings it is a
regulation game in st
louis and with the pending
thunder showers coming the cardinals
grounds crew
well that's all you need to hear right
there uh very smartly getting that tarp
out we're back
at busch stadium and the skies have
cleared up no rain right now
still some clouds overhead and the new
pitcher
is dwayne underwood jr
and the fly ball into left field ben
gammel the catch swing and a miss struck
him out
17 outs two gone here's the three two
swinging a fly ball hit out to right
polanco underneath it
and he makes the catch 18 up 18 down for
pirates pitching
the pirates going into the bottom of the
seventh have
a combined perfect game dylan carlson is
fly to left and fly to center
and the o2 pitch is a base hit it's fair
on the o2 hit off the sidewall
and carlson trots into second base lead
off double
and the cardinals have their first hit
of the afternoon one out runner at third
orinato with a fly ball into right
center carlson will
tag catch made by reynolds
carlson scores and run batted in number
50 for nolan oronato makes it 7-1
runners at first and third here in the
home half of the eight and the batter
will be paul to young
hit into left in an rbi base hit for
paul de young that'll bring in yada yada
molina
cut to lead to seven to two bednar will
see if he can put this one to sleep
very good numbers one ball two strikes
chopped towards short newman to first
raise the jolly roger as max
kranik wow five perfect innings gets
his first big league win